-Our next guest
is an artist, actor,
writer and filmmaker.
Her movie "Kajillionaire"
is in select theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-This is where
the big one starts.
But the noise,
it just keeps building
and building and building.
This one's not building.
The big one will be loud.
I mean, if you're lucky,
you'll get crushed.
And then you'll -- you just di
right then and there.
Immediately.
A never-ending void.
-Wow. So, YOLO.
-Please welcome to the sho
Miranda July.
Hello, Miranda.
-Hi there, Seth.
-I am so excited you're here
We've been trying to have you on
for a while.
-Yeah.
I don't know if you remember
We've actually met once before
-I didn't think
that you would remember.
-[ Laughs ]
No, I do, I do.
You were -- So, you were
coming out of an elevator
and I was going in,
and you turned.
Do you remember
what you said to me?
-Not --
-[ Laughs ]
You said, "I love you."
And then the doors shut.
Which a lot of people might have
taken the wrong way, right
Like, people might have though
you meant "I love your work"
or "you're so cool," but I kne
hat you meant "I love you.
-I do.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-So, uh, can we talk about
your movie "Kajillionaire"
I thought it was fantastic
-Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]
It's a movie about, like, low --
I would say a lower-tier famil
of con men.
Is that an accurate way
of describing it?
-Right, right,
not very good at their job
-Not particularly good
and, you know, I know your wor
over the years and as we hav
established, I'm a fan of it
It's often autobiographica
to some degree.
Is there any of you
in this family?
Any of you in these characters
-Do you mean am I
a low-level con artist?
-Well, yeah, I mean, I guess
that's what I'm getting at
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I will say in the, like
embarrassingly entitled
punk youth that I had,
there was sort of a cultur
of stealing and I did --
I stopped
and I don't condone that.
I remember, like,
a turning point for me was
I was, like, a guest artist,
visiting artist.
I was 23.
I probably should have
been in college,
not being a guest artist,
but I remember kind of
scoping out the room,
as was my habit, for what
I could take on the way out.
Like, maybe a box of chalk
or that video projector
or something.
And then, I caught myself
and I suddenly realized,
"Oh, you can either be thi
sort of respected artist perso
or you can have
the box of chalk."
-[ Laughs ]
-And I guess I made
a choice there.
-Yeah, those were
your two paths.
And we're certainly happy with
the one you picked.
I've read that you got
this idea sort of half asleep,
the idea for this film,
and usually,
I would say most writers would
tell you the ideas they ge
when you're half asleep,
you wake up in the morning
and you realize it was not
a particularly good idea.
How quickly did you know
that there was something here?
-Not very quickly.
I just want to say that
for all the writers out there.
I had to withhold judgment
You know, it seemed
for the better part of a year,
like, kind of a silly idea
You know, these cons
and what does this all mean?
Why waste my life on this?
And then I got to the end
and read it back,
and it kind of punched me
in the gut.
And I guess at that moment
I was like,
"Oh, maybe that is the movie
Maybe that's the ride."
Like, you're laughing,
you're laughing,
you're laughing, you're crying
-And this is a film that -
I mean,
anxiety is a real theme
of this film,
not just the idea of an
earthquake, but also financial
economic, and family anxiety
and it must be so strange
to have it come out at a time --
obviously, you made it
before all this happened -
in this hot bed of anxiety now
-Yeah.
I know. It's so strange.
That anxiety was really personal
to me, and a lot of the themes
like the sensitivity to touc
and just the strangeness
of this lead character --
Old Dolio is her name,
played by Evan Rachel Wood
And now, suddenly
those subtle themes
are, like, front and center.
Like, those are not
my weird thing.
That's, like, the world's
weird thing now.
We're all Old Dolio.
-I also want to congratulate you
on this monograph.
This is a book about you
that you had other people
basically contribute.
I think it's like 80 peopl
that basically talk about you.
Was that terrifying to tur
over, sort of give the key
to families and friends
to tell your story?
-Yeah, I think I thought
I would like that.
You know how you secretly fear
that you're a narcissist?
You know, like, you maybe take
the narcissist test online
and you're like, "Am I?"
And I found out real quick
like, actually,
it turns out I'm not.
Like, I hit my threshold
immediately and just had t
disassociate for most of the
experience of making that book
and pretend that everyone
was talking about somebody els
and I was just maybe
working for that person,
making her book for her.
-It must be so strange too
because obviously people are
giving you materials,
and then, you have to --
because part of it is you take
yourself out of it, right,
and then you get this incredible
reflection of somebody.
Because I think sometimes with
autobiographies, you know,
you're obviously getting
one person's perspective.
It's so multi-layered
to have a bunch of people,
but at the same time,
you're the gatekeeper.
Was that a weird responsibilit
to have?
-I think I thought it woul
be more accurate that way.
Like, I was actually assigne
to write about myself,
and everything I started t
write didn't --
it didn't seem true.
Everything was true, but i
didn't add up to the truth
You know what I mean?
And so, even if
some of my friends'
or collaborators' stories are,
like, a little off
or it's, like,
just their version,
somehow collectively,
it's more a life.
-It's really wonderful,
and one of my favorite --
before you go, I should say that
of the many things you've done
one of my favorite things
you ever did was
an interview with Rihanna,
I believe,
in "The New York Times"
back in 2015.
You know, I have long been
enamored with Rihanna.
But that interview
was the first time
I realized truly
how fun she was.
Was that as much fun
to basically spend that time
with her as it was to read
-Yes, I mean, we both are
drunk with Rihanna.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
Although, she was
drunk with you,
whereas I think I was
the only one who would, like
nervously drunk in myself.
I mean, I -- Yeah, I mean,
she's just so lovely.
Right?
-Yeah.
-I'm so jealous that you reall
hung out with her like that.
-Yeah, I mean, I'm just
so sad it's over.
And it's been over
for like over a year.
-[ Laughs ] I know.
-I'm still just,
like, working through
that it's probably
not going to happen again.
-I remember her assistant --
like, I had to do
some last-minute fact checking
or something,
and her assistant signed off
saying something like, you know,
"See you around" or something.
And for the whole, like,
next week, I was, like, ready.
Like, they were going to
call me to hang out.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I was like,
telling everyone, like,
"I don't know.
We have pl-- you know,
she said, 'See you around.
So that's -- you know, it'
probably in the next few days.
And then, someone pointed out,
like, that's just what people --
that's like, "Bye."
-Yeah, 'cause that was 2015.
I feel like those plans woul
have probably firmed up by now
-I mean, I guess --
Yeah, yeah, no, you're right
-Miranda, it has been so lovel
to have you here.
The film is great.
Congratulations
on the book as well,
and I would like
to close the way we began,
by saying I love you.
-Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]